ann heyche is facing a multitude of of
charges most of them are misdemeanors
she's facing potentially driving under
the influence of alcohol or drugs
hit and run and potentially some type of
reckless endangerment
for the reckless driving that occurred
right before the crash
keep in mind that each of these charges
are misdemeanor charges there is a
potential for up to six months in jail
fines as well as having her license
suspended for quite a lengthy period of
time
assuming that the toxicology reports
would come back in for favor i still
think she's facing at least a
hit-and-run charge and a reckless charge
and the reason is whether she was
using alcohol or drugs she still a acted
recklessly she was driving at a very
high rate of speed we know that she hit
at least one structure and instead of
staying behind contacting the police and
giving her identification she drove off
and hit another structure so i think
that's going to be very tough for her
and her attorneys to defend
the police obtained a search warrant to
get blood from anheesh and
the prosecutors obviously are hoping
that it's within three hours because
that's when the results would be the
most reliable
there's going to be a test done on the
blood to determine a whether there was
alcohol in her system and if so how much
alcohol was in her system and the second
question is were there drugs in her
system if there were they're going to do
follow-up tests to determine what type
of drug was in her system and again how
much of that drug was in her system once
they determine there's drugs in an
individual system the next test is to
determine how much of those drugs were
in her system you can have alcohol in
your system you can have had arguably a
drink and still be allowed to drive the
issue is whether or not when it comes to
alcohol it's over the legal limit drugs
is a little different because in a sense
it really doesn't matter how much of the
drug you have it's if it's an illegal
drug or if it's a drug you're not
allowed to use when you're driving
whether it's a little or a lot you can
still be charged
either way i believe anne haiti is going
to be charged with something now we have
to wait for the toxicology reports to
come back to determine whether or not
there's going to be enough to charge her
with driving while under the influence
the first thing law enforcement has to
determine is whether or not there is
alcohol in her system if there was was
the amount of alcohol above the legal
limit the second question is whether or
not there's drugs in her system and if
there were what type of drugs are these
drugs that would inhibit in any way her
ability to drive these are the questions
that they're going to want to ask before
they decide the exact
charges into a structure we also have a
structured fire two-story single-family
dwelling
heavy smoke showing
there is a victim in this case that's
the woman whose house was damaged and
set on fire and there's several things
that can happen first during the
criminal proceeding there can be
restitution
um
during that that sentencing phase if in
fact she's found guilty the second thing
is she can file a civil suit against ann
heish for the damage that she caused to
her property they're going to
remove the body from the vehicle and
probably transport the victim
to a hospital we all hope that anne h
gets better we we know
right now she's in the hospital and so i
don't think there's anyone out there
that wants
anything but the best for her at the
same time if in fact she has alcohol and
drugs in her system and or drugs in her
system
any attorney is going to tell her first
do not speak to anyone other than the
attorney because anything you say can be
used against you the second thing i
would do immediately is get her into
alcohol and or drug treatment that is
probably the most important thing the
last thing you want is for this to ever
happen again
anytime someone is in the hospital it
makes it difficult for law enforcement
to proceed and so it slows the process
down keep in mind
that ann heishi isn't going anywhere
it's not like she can up and leave and
so the assumption is that if in fact she
gets better once she is they will arrest
her and bring her before a judge
who will at that time
potentially suspend her license and then
the case will move forward assuming the
lapd and the district attorney's office
decides to go forward with the case
there's no question they're going
forward with the case it would be crazy
crazy if they didn't
crazy now take into consideration the
fact that anne his persona is so
important to her livelihood
it becomes even more serious now do i
believe at the end of the day she's
going to do serious jail time i i don't
i i'm hopeful
that if she is arrested that she'll get
the help that it seems that she needs
but can it have a permanent effect first
of all having a criminal record
certainly and can it have an impact on
her ability to work in the profession
she's worked in all her life it
certainly can
[Music]
you